there's a guy on Tik Tok who is reacting
to me the man's name is Joshua Joseph 19
years old Tik tocker and the video he
made about me has 2.3 million views hold
on I'm making this guy famous over here
but let's see what he had to say you've
just said that when you consent to sex
you are acknowledging the possibility of
becoming pregnant and consenting to that
it's consent to the possibility of
pregnancy then it is consent to
pregnancy no it's not but I do consent
to running laps around daily wire dumb
until Candace Owens responds to me so
here we go honestly this one makes me
super upset because in this scenario the
doctor should have probably called Child
Protective Services I think this clip
and people like Michael Noles are a
direct product of when we let intuition
supersede critical thinking put pause
when we engage in scientific reasoning
that would be reasoning about uh Eternal
things when we engage in philosophical
wisdom that's a type of reasoning all of
that is premised on specifically
intuitive reasoning because you need to
establish certain premises to even
engage in scientific inquiry or what he
is calling here critical thinking I'm
thinking I'm thinking you have to begin
with certain assumptions that you just
take on faith so I know this is only a
minor part of his argument I suspect
probably because he gets the premises
wrong that's where he will go wrong at
the end but you can't downplay intuition
intuitive reasoning is a prerequisite
for any other kind of thinking including
so-called critical thinking that he's
talking about it's funny because these
people are so dog at making arguments
that he literally almost dis proves his
own line of thinking while he's talking
watch if I consent to go to the bar and
I know that if I go to the bar there's a
possibility that I get drunk I am
consenting to that hangover that I am
going to have that will involve some
suffering and maybe teach me some
lessons but one thing you just
completely skipped over the getting
drunk part going to a bar does not by
default mean that you consent to being
drunk huh I want to pause it on his
point because he says just because you
go to the bar doesn't mean that you
consent to get drunk
julan the flaw in his vision here is
that he's viewing consent as a purely
rational fact rather than something that
is influenced by emotion and concupisent
and appetite and Temptation so what he's
missing here is a concept that
Christians know very well which is the
idea of the near occasion of sin oh yeah
it's all coming together much as in this
case of going to the bar if you're if
you know that you're prone to getting
drunk and you choose to go to a bar on a
Saturday night late at night you are
beginning the process of consenting to
get
drunk drink cup let's boo boo and the
reason why I think people like him get
away with saying stupid like this is
because the word consent is being
woefully misused let's take a look at
the definition of consent permission for
something to happen or an agreement to
do something now I don't know how
successful Michael NOS is with the
ladies but uh news flash if a woman
gives you permission to have sex with
them you are not then permitted by
default to give them a child yes this is
something that that he's missing too
he's missing the idea that things are
for purposes sex has all sorts of nice
fun things attached to it but the point
of sex is procreation what he's trying
to do here and what all the people who
make consent the only moral Criterion is
they're trying to divorce things from
their purposes but things are defined by
their purposes unfortunately in modern
liberal life we just take all of that
away and we say no nothing's for
anything at all what a lot of them say
is well the re the purpose of life is
just to have
[Music]
fun if it feels good do it you know
that's ultimately what the moral maximum
comes in which is totally irrational and
unjustifiable but it's just an implicit
fill in to a shallow liberal notion of
politics which says that consent is all
that matters you going to have sex with
me no James I don't want to yes you do
okay yes see that 50 NOS in a Yes means
yes right now go to Jus cell.com
nsyt as you might know we are all big
fans of our friends over at genus cell
don't just take my word for it Ella from
Rockford says quote I have both age and
acne spots and this stuff is actually
fading both of them this Serum is worth
every penny Ella is a raving about the
famous Dark Spot Corrector from genell a
must have after months of record heat
and humidity sunspots brown spots
discoloration and even red inflamed
patches all disappear in front of your
very eyes and here's the J cell amazing
guarantee you will see results on day
one or your money back so take advantage
of genus cell's most popular package
which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic genus cell
bags and puffiness treatment and
immediate effects all at about 70 70%
off so you can try the best skincare in
the world for yourself completely
risk-free it's simple go to genucell.com
nyt and start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say goodbye to dark and
liver spots bags and puffiness on under
the eyes crows feet at Jus cell.com nyt
jus.com letter y letter T one of my main
issues with this dumb line of thinking
is that this logic does not hold up in
any other context because accepting the
risk that something may happen is a
completely different concept than giving
permission for that thing to
[Music]
happen but if any of those things are to
happen to you you wouldn't be expected
to be okay with that nor did you give
the pay for those things to happen and
before you say well the main purpose of
driving is just Transportation the main
purpose of sex is to have a kid nope way
ahead of you there buddy now you can
believe that the main purpose of sex
should be to have a kid all you want but
the fact remains that while historically
put a pause there you put a little pause
in there I like that I'm not saying
historically the reasons why people have
sex are few in number people have sex
for all sorts of reasons I'm saying
philosophically
theologically there is a reason for
which people have sex because it feels
good it does feel good I don't want to
be too harsh on this guy cuz he's so
young and he's clearly curious and
ambitious and wants to be a thinker but
he doesn't even know how to go about
thinking well okay so if you're somebody
who can become pregnant you know you can
and no condoms or contraceptives are
being used then you consent to pregnancy
and even then still no not only would
your original claim need to be walked
back so far to only have a shred of
making sense as long as one or both
parties involved do not want a pregnancy
that action is not being consented to
much in the same way I could drive at
high speeds and bad weather with those
seat belt on I still don't consent to
dying in a car accident or being badly
injured or having a car accident in
general now there is room for one to say
well you shouldn't have been doing that
or whatever you need to be
saf I take the
most while driving and say the Act of
driving means you're consenting to a car
accident I'd look like a damn idiot but
somehow we let these dudes get paid
millions of dollars and get away with it
anyway With viral Clips because as long
as it sounds intuitively correct we shut
our brains off and go ha look at the
dumb woman over there okay I'm not going
to be too harsh on he's very young and
he talks like a very young person who
hasn't who hasn't thought very much in
my opinion you're an idiot common sense
is pretty reliable our modern liberal
culture tells us that it isn't our
modern liberal culture tells us there
that there is nothing worse than
Prejudice nobody likes you you girl now
hold on a second the liberal
rationalists who really began to rise to
the four after the enlightenment they're
the kinds of people they will use their
stock of reason they will ignore
Prejudice they'll ignore history they'll
ignore common sense and they will say
using my little stock of reason and the
the new knowledge that I'm going to
impose upon the world I'm going to
explain how it's good to kill little
babies I'm going to explain how men and
women are exactly the same and they're
not complimentary I'm going to explain
how every smart person for all of human
history was wrong and I'm right right
you simplify reality so much that it
becomes absurd and meaningless and when
you try try to apply that kind of
reasoning to all manner of situations
you arrive at really really heinous
conclusions such as
infanticide listen you got at least 34s
of your life to go that's three more
lifetimes to you so don't blow it get
some help McDonald's wants you to give
yourself a chance a chance to find out
all the wonderful things you really can
be and so do
I
the F you looking
at